Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan. Wir stehen wieder in der Garderobe, denn es ist Live-Salon. 200 Leute sitzen im Saal. Und wir wollen dieses Mal nicht, nicht über KI sprechen. Wir werden nicht über Sam Altman, irgendwelche Chatbots, Fake News, all das sprechen, oder?
Aber wir können noch mal kurz hinweisen, Mustafa Zuleyman, nachdem wir ihn besprochen haben, haben die bei Microsoft unseren Podcast gehört und haben gedacht, der Typ ist klug. Das wird der neue Microsoft AI CEO.
Ja, also wir sind am Puls der Zeit. Wer das noch nachhören will, das gibt es im aktuellen Salon. Aber jetzt geht es zum Live-Salon. Wir haben uns gedacht, dann stellen wir doch jetzt mal den Menschen in den Mittelpunkt. Der Mensch mit all seinen Begehrlichkeiten. Deshalb wird es ums Dating gehen. Du hast dich intensiv mit dieser Vox Sendung First Dates beschäftigt.
First Dates, wahrscheinlich eine der ausuferndsten Recherchen zu diesem Podcast. Wochenlang habe ich Vox geguckt. Und ja, man hört dann gleich im Salon die Quintessenz von allem.
Ja, und ich habe mich auch gefragt, wie verhalten sich eigentlich Menschen in Datingsituationen? Zum Beispiel, deswegen habe ich ein paar Clips mitgebracht zum Bachelor. Dann habe ich mich aber auch gefragt, was ist das eigentlich für eine Haltung, die wir Zuschauer einnehmen, wenn wir dort Leute sehen, die doch eigentlich nicht spielen, sondern authentisch sind oder dann doch vielleicht spielen? Das heißt, unsere ganzen Debatten über was ist Wirklichkeit? Was ist Fiktion? Was ist Fake News? Und was ist das Echte? Das können wir eigentlich auch sehr gut mal an dem festmachen, was wir an Unterhaltungen konsumieren. Deswegen werden wir ein bisschen über Reality-Fernsehen sprechen. Ich habe dann ein interessantes TikTok-Phänomen entdeckt, nämlich von einer Anbahnung zu einer Beziehung. Da ist eine junge Frau und ein junger Mann, die leben in einer WG. Es sind aber Schauspieler, die spielen das, aber trotzdem scheint es irgendwie doch echt zu sein, zumindest was die Interaktion der Zuschauer anbelangt. Und da kommen wir in ein Feld, wo wir am Ende vielleicht diese klassische Unterscheidung, die wir immer so machen, das ist gespielt und das ist aber echt, überhaupt hinfällig wird.
Weißt du dann auch, wie wir bei Taylor Lawrence, die Geschichte von Lonely Girl 15 oder wie auch immer, wir sind jetzt schon wieder im Lonely Girl Zeitalter wahrscheinlich. Nur eben andere Methoden, aber...
Ja, und eine ganz neue Art des Erzählens, denn eigentlich passiert dort auf TikTok die Seifenoper, die wir aus dem täglichen Fernsehen kennen. Das machen die dort bei TikTok nur in ganz kurzer Form. Also auch darüber wird zu reden sein.
Ja, war ja deine Lektüre-These auch beim letzten Mal TikTok ist das neue Fernsehen. Was ist das neue Buch, das wir lesen?
Wir lesen von Martin Hegelund, dieses eine Leben, Glaube jenseits der Religion, Freiheit jenseits des Kapitalismus. Und dieser Autor hat die These, naja, so ganz ohne zu glauben kommen wir eigentlich auch nicht durch die Welt. Aber wir haben auch nur dieses eine Leben. Wir können uns jetzt nicht auf die Religion einfach so gerufen. Aber wir müssen vielleicht doch den Glauben nicht aufgeben. Ich hab's auch noch nicht gelesen, aber es klingt sehr spannend. Es wird weltweit viel rezipiert und ist gerade erschienen.
Dazu noch eine These, nicht eine These, eine Pointe, die ich heute Morgen gehört habe. Viele Sachen, die wir bisher an die Kirche oder die Religion angebunden haben, werden jetzt davon entbunden säkularisiert, zum Beispiel Friedhöfe. Es gibt also neuerdings Friedhöfe in Form von Gebäuden, kennt man so weit, Grufte oder wie auch immer. In dem Fall ging es darum, dass derjenige, der die Standards für die Friedhofs- und Begräbnissoftware, man hat ja dann noch mal mit Formularen zu tun oder so, sehr viel Geld damit gemacht hat, das zu digitalisieren, dieses Geld nahm, um so eine Art moderne Gruft, also ein ganz säkularisierter Ort, wo man seine Urne lässt, also eine Pilgerstätte für Urnen. Man kann sich das jetzt grob mit Regalen vorstellen, das ist natürlich ein bisschen ästhetisch aufgehübscht. Warum kam das in Deutschland erst zu spät, also lange gar nicht zustande? Es war der Brandschutz, der denen im Wege stand. Man konnte die Urnen mit der Asche nicht unterbringen, weil der Brandschutz dem entgegenstand. Das ist natürlich deine Nummer zu profan. Aber soweit kann man es treiben.
Wir schauen mal, ob wir da eine Alternativreligion bekommen oder ob es tatsächlich ein Glaubensgerüst ist, das ohne Religion auskommt und ob wir das überhaupt brauchen, ob wir nicht auch ganz ohne das auskommen können. Wir sind sehr gespannt. Du musst noch kurz sagen, wie man am besten jetzt diesen Live-Salon und auch alle anderen Salons hören kann.
Man geht auf Neuezwanziger.de und folgt dem goldenen Schein des deutlichsten Buttons, der dort ist. Dann kommt man zu Steady, unsere Lieblingseinflugschneise, weil da das ganze Archiv vollständig ist, lückenlos. Alle Kapitelmarken sind drin, alle Literaturen sind genannt. Aber man kann natürlich auch über Apple hören, wenn man es einfach mag, weil wir da einfach die Salonfolgen im normalen Apple-Feed einspielen. Oder per Patreon, wenn man schon einen Account hat. Und Account Armut. Das ist eigentlich ein kleiner Widerspruch. Man hat schon einen Patreon-Account und wir fordern einen Account Armut ein. Aber falls es bei jemandem so ist, dann kann man bei Patreon einfach buchen.
Oder man kann einfach, wenn man den Podcast bei Spotify hört, auch dort auf den Button gehen, wird dann zum Steady-Salon gelotst. Alles ganz einfach. Und wir freuen uns und gehen jetzt gleich auf die Bühne. Hallo.
Wir begrüßen euch.